hallo mein name ist lucanet sich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
des mycroft beta let's play heute ist
dienstag und deswegen kommt dieses
display und das ex playboy uncut
deswegen ab jetzt uncut weiter wir waren
letztes mal hier stehengeblieben wurde
auf dieses spiel geschaut haben die da
oben ganz alleine saß ich glaube die
sonne geht gerade wieder unter das heißt
wir müssten erstmal ganz kurz was
fressen und dann bmw- und unten in die
links ich kann ja nicht durchlaufen ich
doof trottel alter ist stimmt haben wir
ja in der letzten teil der rat hier
verwenden also ich laufe hin begebe mich
in mein schlafgemach ab hier rein zakir
wieder die erde neben wegnehmen und ich
sage euch freuen in diesem papier können
auch nicht bereit diese kann ich über
nacht schlafen daraus waren schon längst
nacht oder die sonne ist am helllichten
sorry ich muss kurzen ganz kleinen
katzen und mir ganz kurz auf die
schnauze hauen bin zurück freunde ja ich
weiß nicht ich habe gerade irgendwie
dieses video angefangen und dachte mir
halt irgendwie okay ich stehe da drin
guckt nach oben und irgendwie so dunkel
aus aber die sonne ist da oben von ok
alles klien als fresh alles perfekt ich
wohl noch ein bisschen mehr holz welcher
noch ein bisschen mehr fans es brauche
damit das ganze aussieht und damit ich
habe mich als wäre ich in so ein
komischer ein richter aus einem
möbelhaus in einem sagt ja und danach
die bitte nach diesem müll bilden die
den saft hemmt sie aus dem vergleich mit
dem kommissions- zusammen und ich
probiere das jetzt mal ganz kurz zu
machen wie ich denke wie es gut aussahen
ausschauen wir das heißt ich packe dass
man den setzlingen ich packe jedoch ein
setzlingen dann packe ich einfach mal
hier noch ein setzlingen und hier oben
vielleicht liegt hier auf dem baum raus
und ich hab noch einer kommt übrigens
oft box
fakt mich schon wieder übel ab weil die
ganze zeit nur am klimpern ist hier die
flackert die ganzheitlich hat schon eine
neue firma bestellt aber die sich so
hell hört ihr das wenn ich zwischen weil
ich guck mal ganz kurz in die in die cam
hier ob man das sieht ich glaube man
sieht an dem kissen was im background
stehe das kissen gibt es im lukas keine
einblendung weil ich wollte nicht so
viel kappen aber sieht man das bei dem
kissen warte ich muss man ganz gut also
ist ja auch egal ich kann jetzt gerade
während der aufnahme ist an ändern
aber nur damit ihr wisst woran es liegt
falls es hier so ein bisschen epilepsie
mäßig aussieht so 16 fans müssten glaube
ich reichen einfach für den rest gibt
packe ich mal hier überall dran so genau
und dann wollte ich unbedingt noch diese
teile hier weg machen weil hier auch
steine hin sollten die quasi rund um rom
gezogen werden um das haus ich weiß das
wird jetzt kein übel kreishaus wo wir
direkt sagt jason terry pratchett
architektur sondern es wird mehr so
dieses top box fakt nicht überlappen
also wenn ihr das video gerade seht ist
dienstag und das ist das letzte video
was ich von urlaub vor produzieren muss
also ich nehme quasi diesen teil
minecraft gerade eine halbe stunde im
anschluss an das letzte video was in
dieser reihe kommt deswegen
ich stand hat scheinen und hoffe dann
zerfällt also nicht deswegen wenn ihr
morgen das video seht morgens wenn alles
gut läuft kommt das video am 16.8
seit dem morgen das video seht wie flash
back aus dem urlaub die spinnt schild da
oben immer noch tatsächlich das da kann
ich allerdings auch nix für ich werde
jetzt mal überlegen wie ich das ganze in
die kur machen kann ich hab 43 glas
weist allerdings nicht wo das hin soll
ich würde am liebsten von unten nach
oben glas bauen
aber ich überlege auch schon eine seite
irgendwie zu zumachen zu einer seite wo
es nicht so schön aus sie dahin muss auf
jeden fall offen dahin auch nach hierhin
kommen nach ihren bei euch zu dann baue
ich hier einfach noch so ein pineapple
hin
sein bruder hier so zack zack zack und
dann baue ich das am besten zu mit boah
ich weiß gar nicht also ich wollte
eigentlich die fenster so machen sie das
scheiße aus [ __ ] [ __ ] you ich weiß gar
nicht wann soll ich wollte eigentlich
bist du hier so steigen dann alles sind
inzwischen so verdammt
und da oben muss ja auch noch und ich
hab gar keine spitzhacke alter schwede
mensch hat bin ich wieder super
vorbereitet hier auf das leben also der
nehmen einfach mal ganz schnell das
einpacken dass der reinpasst dix packen
wieder runter nehmen uns die pigs packen
die hier hinnehmen die packs nehmen die
pc's und werfen dahin wo wir ein
bisschen stein gönnen können steinen
können gönnen können genau
und der kommt jetzt gleich da oben hin
und hier das die ganze werde ich zu
einem der letzten folge schon gesagt
komplett mit erde ausgleichen so dass
sie erstens nichts bond und zweitens das
ganze nicht so blöd aussieht wenn wir da
drauf gucken aber das wird alles noch
kommen
ich habe immer überlegt ihn mal live
streams zu machen wenn ihr theoretische
wollt dass sich im livestream mache aus
diesem projekt von wegen ich hab eine
arbeit die will ich nicht aufs spiel und
macht halt off screen einfach aber
schreibt mir die kommentare livestream
wenn die erde
ich denke die ganze zeit draußen kracht
gegen vogel gerade gegen die scheibe das
ist einfach diese softbox ich habe mein
mikro also eingestellt dass ihr das
nicht hört was hinter der kam
ich freue mich jetzt ganz kurzen card
und versuche das man eben kurz zu
reparieren
ich habe alles getan was ich tun konnte
ich habe mehrmals gegen geschlagen ich
die lampe raus gedreht 3 o gott es ist
schon nacht gerade dem solange ich habe
ganz vergessen auch für skate zu drücken
will aufgefallen ich habe alles getan
was ich euch die flackert immer noch
nicht dass warte ich beobachte man ganz
kurz gleich wenn ich im bett liege das
flackern ob das wirklich so krass wie
ich das will ich dass gerade hier in
meinen augen legen
ich spüre nicht dass jetzt direkt wieder
eine spinne sport oder in so ein
schwachsinn soll hier erde hinweg
reinsetzen
doch man sieht kratz hier da hinten da
da da sieht man es da an meinem kopf
vorbei wenn das plakat da sieht man's
rettet achtung es flackert da darf man
es gesehen
sorry ich werde morgen bin ich aus dem
urlaub zurück will war die leute
vielleicht nicht sagen dass die lampe
jetzt tatsächlich irgendwie drei wochen
oder drei stunden am stück an war weil
ich die ganze zeit videos produziert
habe aber ich muss ja auch eigentlich
mein weg hoch bauen so also was ich
jetzt machen wollte ist da oben steine
hin so stein habe ich genug geholt da
hab ich jetzt mittlerweile 37 stück die
sollten eigentlich reichen glaube ich
und jetzt muss ich halt wieder oben hin
kommen da gibt's hat nun dem weg dahin
muss hier auch noch treppen hoch bauen
sodass ich halt wirklich nicht die ganze
zeit über dieses bescheuerte ehrt
konstrukt hier laufen muss das soll
alles noch ein bisschen spinne soll als
noch ein bisschen schöner werden das
heißt hier erst mal steine hin kommt
eigentlich auch ein stein
da kommt kein stein aber ich packte
einfach nicht einfach fürs auge bis hier
damit wenn man von dieser seite kommt
damit das nicht irgendwie obwohl man
kommt glaube ich nie von dieser seite
oder ich muss mal gucken warum ich diese
seite überhaupt gebaut habe ist mir bis
jetzt noch nicht so ganz klar
also ja okay hier weiter hier
dann packen wir hier wollte ich ja auch
noch dann steine hin packen dich kann
ich hier keinen von den zahn
man man man so so so so und so bei
diesen teilen ich weiß nicht soll ich
dir noch ein stückchen die müsste ich
eigentlich noch ein stückchen höher
bauen und dann halt fackeln drauf an dem
ich auf welche hier sind jedoch oder da
es eine acht das ist nun der aus der
ecke
das sieht nicht geil aus attacke so hier
einer da einer so hier hier hier und
hier könnte halte eine dachterrasse
drauf halt auch noch mit ein paar
fenster
ich weiß natürlich wie man dahin kommt
ich kann theoretisch eine treppe von
unten also sonne leiter von unten hoch
bauen
das heißt ich packe hier oben aber jetzt
erst mal ein paar fackeln drauf so dass
sie für den ersten moment nichts bond
man das ja auch durchaus die wege die
jetzt hier hinführen
auch luca was habe ich da wieder für
eine scheiße gebaut
jdx darauf zu springen nein natürlich
nicht
gewichtiger luca wäre gewesen wenn jetzt
in die höhle unten rein gefallen wäre
das natürlich auch cool gewesen
hey wie mach ich das denn jetzt
es gehört lampe ist voll die [ __ ]
mir gefällt mir das ja alles noch nicht
so richtig
mann ich hab ein bisschen blöd ich weiß
auch nicht was jetzt im tür hin
am besten wäre es glaube ich wenn der wk
ich habe eine idee wie ich das mache
sorry dass das hier gerade so bau folgen
sind aber muss ja auch sein meine damen
und herren also ist ich kann es ihnen
nicht
bisher kann er nicht alles immer spaß
machen also ich meine mir macht spaß
aber wahrscheinlich zum zuschauen nicht
aber vielleicht auch doch gerade
deswegen dafür bräuchte ich themen ich
habe zwar am letzten in der letzten
folge gesagt ja alter schwede
holen so also nein nicht deine mutter
von der lampe zwischen eine tolle frau
aber [ __ ] hast du scheiße wirklich
ihr habt extra die birne ausgetauschten
alles und es funktioniert
vielleicht sollte vielleicht sollte ich
echt mal ein neues equipment investieren
soll ich vielleicht mal machen na ja ich
wollte die folge heute eh nicht so krass
lange halten das die letzte folge alter
hat mich die mich gerade ab fakt aber
ich will darüber gar nicht mein handy
vibriert die ganze zeit wegen gegen
welche nachrichten weil ich ja gleich in
urlaub fahren die lampe bild ich habe
hier irgendwie alles falsch gebaut und
mein leben geht den bach runter
gerade wirklich wegen minecraft und
wegen leben und leben auch weil leben ja
genau so so war ich jetzt mal dann kann
ich auch irgendwie türen hinsetzen vista
so habe ich die fackeln extra jetzt
läuft das hier nämlich auch setze ich
hier eine fackel in wissen und hier
jetzt machen wir nämlich hier in 1 23
abstand dann kommt hier eine hin die
hier kommen weg 1 23 abstand hier kommt
eine hin die hier kommt natürlich auch
weg 123 abstand dann komme ich hier eine
hin man scheiße hier auf den 3 wayne
also die meist dass man ihnen zwei
abstand zwar schon besser aus weil die
schau mal
so so so sind auf einer diesen auf einer
höhe hier einer hin da einer hin da ja
ich mache so als ich eben ich meine ich
stelle mir das hier so vor dass hier
holzknüppel hinkommen wo ich das denn
jetzt getan
das scheißegal hier kommen holzknüppel
hin nicht so komisch ist hier eigentlich
so dass man fensters mit der spitzhacke
stelle ab und kann ich glaub schon weil
vergleicht mal spitze holz spitzhacke
und stein axt ich glaube die mit eisen
spitzhacke abbauen würde wären sie
direkt instant weg als ich brauch
holzstämme da die mittig nicht abfällt
ist ein großer baum das bild wir können
eigentlich schön stehen lassen so als
big baba baum directly wir nehmen jetzt
nämlich die holz kübel holz kübel sind
es nicht sondern holzstämmen luca packen
die hierhin gab es schon schräge setzen
nein gab es nicht okay wir befinden uns
nicht in der neuesten minecraft sollen
eine beschissene minecraft ist luca das
hast du natürlich wieder vergessen
jetzt laufen wir hier ein es wird schon
ein bisschen das muss man sagen ich will
das ja auch noch ein bisschen anders
bauen hier vorne das sieht schon besser
aus nach nimwegen spinne davon ist bei
die alles klar bei dir
wir nehmen hier den holz klumpen machen
hier eine tür hin eine hör doch auf zu
flackern alter buren liegt das macht es
aus so mal wieder an die flackert die
ganze zeit ich mache dir gleich noch
zwei tür nicht blöd blog kopf voller
meerholz es tut mir leid mit dem
flackern freund des formulars der
komplette teil
ich raste aus paris hat setzt und
zwischendurch mal die einnahmen für den
wenn man abseits abkürzung fingen
irgendwie abkürzung für vollidiot
voller vorfreude es gibt keinen chat es
gibt kein chat in welcher wer so wie ich
hier gelandet
gibt es doppelt türen alter wenn es
jetzt auch keine doppelte gibt dann
häufig aber das habe ich erst jetzt
werde ich mir extra eine scheintür
kräften am ende doppelt zu machen
wenn es dann keine doppelten gibt
freunde ich bin komplett am ende also
wir nennen die lampe weit idee von voll-
und idee von idiot
detroit ok es funktioniert wir haben die
tür
das ist jetzt unser eingang packen wir
darüber noch stone damit wir ein
verbundenes element haben zum rest von
haus und jetzt kann theoretisch jeder
hier kann man kann dich an den fans
vorbei okay das kann quasi keiner rein
oder schreibt mir die kommentare wenn er
doch eine rein kann aber ich bin mir
gerade nicht sicher ehrlich gesagt so
dann packe ich hier nochmal die hindern
sieht das so ein bisschen cooler aus
jetzt könnte ich theoretisch alter
schwede
ich könnte das theoretisch alles
überdacht machen alter ich habe ideen
freunde
man man man ich werde nicht mehr
also ich denke wir könnten die
mittlerweile schon schlafen wenn wir das
problem da hinten gelöst hätten
aber wir machen hier erstmal auf jeden
zweiten block sollten glaube ich fackeln
drauf so ja genau
hier eine da kommt leider weg tut mir
leid hier eine hier eine du kommst auch
leider weg hier eine hier eine erstmal
und jetzt hier auf dieser seite hier
eine hier eine hier eine hier eine und
die ich mache ich auch mal ganz gut weg
weil ich jetzt nicht weiß wie ich genau
hier rein gehen soll
ich überlege gerade hier müssen auch
irgendwo in die gerade einfachen weg
nach da hinten zumachen dann hier in der
luft felder zu setzen weil ich glaube
das mache ich weil das projekt so ein
bisschen selbstverwirklichung in
minecraft seien für mich so dass ich das
mache worauf ich eigentlich schon immer
so richtig bock hatte
das heißt ich machen weg war sie
hierdurch irgendwie ja doch der fängt
schon an
sodann in etwa ja genau dass er hier so
lang geht
versteht ihr wie ich meine gerade ich
denke nicht ehrlich gesagt weil ich
gerade doch noch ein bisschen in rätseln
spreche also guckt man hier mit der
spitzhacke wie schnell das geht dann
bauen wir jetzt ab jetzt einfach nur
noch mit einer spitze gab okay ich
glaube es gibt genauso schnell wie mit
einer scheiß steinachs aber ich bin mir
gerade nicht so richtig sicher wollen
wir dich kurz weg die ich bei ihr kurz
weg ich habe auch gar keinen fressen
mehr dann muss ich auch mal wieder
machen an dem wir hier kurz noch den
iran edeka-tochter kann stehen bleiben
der kann sogar stehen bleiben zu den
hier toll jetzt komme ich dann nicht
mehr hoch alles klar luca aber dann
sammeln ich mal ganz kurz die items die
ich hier habt fallen lassen so zac jetzt
werde ich will dass am liebsten auch in
diesem part zu ende machen aber ich will
nicht dass die tat zu lange werden
natürlich können die tat zu lange werden
klar also schnallt das ja nicht nachher
das heißt ich sitze nicht anderthalb
stunden nachher noch im schnitt dran wie
an anderen videos an real live videos
und wo er presste button und heiler
gamer hier derzeit relativ häufig aber
ich hätte trotzdem nicht so lange weil
ich will jetzt nicht dass ihre box set
euro 30 minuten minecraft ist eigentlich
kugel aber es viel zu lange bis sie wie
ich mein so da ich sage übel auf wisst
ihr wie ich meine
bist du dich mal wie ich finde das video
sofort wartet schild noch ganz kurz ich
mache nämlich noch hier eben dass ihr
noch mal ganz kurz seht die das ganze
nachher aussehen soll dieser pop
nämlich auch noch weg und an der block
darunter dann kann ich euch dass ihr
auch schon direkt zeigen die zwei ist
steine sind mir eigentlich nicht egal
aber hier kommt jetzt den weg lang
freunde und sogar direkt nacht
wahrscheinlich wird auch genau so macht
wie am anfang der folge aber hier kommt
dem weg lang direkt durch die mittel
dann immer links rechts kommen so ein
paar sachen wieder im felder unserem
scheiß wisst ihr
da habe ich gerade übel bock drauf und
das ist so das ziel was wir dann im
nächsten video so ein bisschen verfolgen
werden also ich lass das jetzt erst mal
so stehen so dass luca im nächsten teil
weiß weil ihr müsst ja überlegen ich bin
jetzt gerade vorproduzieren der 16 38
uhr der nächste teil kommst du schon
eine woche für mich kommt der teil aber
erst in drei wochen war ich im urlaub
bin deswegen ich hoffe ihr versteht so
ein bisschen wie ich das ganze
fortsetzen will
also hier quasi noch ich kann die zäune
oder gar nie fand packen gerade so in
die richtung quasi nie so versteht da
ein 2 dann würde jenes fackel stehen und
hier so und dann hier so links rechts
immer so ein paar felder aber ich beende
das videos einfach mal nicht in der
nacht weil das wäre ein bisschen blöd
weil dann staatlich nicht mal das neue
video und werde direkt von zombies
angriffe haben übrigens auch direkt
leben das wäre cool für captain was ich
derzeit mit gong auf seinem kanal spiele
aber für mich gerade nicht so sehr von
bedeutung das heißt ich vorne einfach
dann ich spontan das noch einfach hier
direkt neben meinem bett schlafe jetzt
ein hoffe dass ich irgendwelche zombies
kommen sollte aber glaube ich nicht der
fall sein es müsse jetzt morgen sein
ich logge mich aus meine damen und
herren wenn euch das video gefallen hat
würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen mir macht dieses projekt ultra
viel spaß weil ich einfach lagern kann
ich weiß ich muss keine katzen plan
das sage ich auch am ende jedes papst
aber ich lasse jetzt in ruhe haut rein
diese scheiß leuchten